BULLS  LOOK FOR THE WIN.
DeROZANIT TRULY IS.
>> Kevin: CAM
ALL IN ONE MOTION.
>> Kevin: MAY BE IT WILL GIVE O.
WIDE OPEN AND MITCHELL ROBINSON
REBUILD MODE. AND, DUNKING IT.
BEATING HIM TO LOLOPOST CARD AS
STAYS AT THE WHAT >> SPEAKING O
POSITIONS.
SOMETIMES THERE'S A PERCEPTION
THAT YOU DON'T WORK HARD IN THE
RIGHT THERE I THINK HE
CAN FEEL HISOF THE
YEAR.
>>Dante: THREE FOUL IS ON-- BL
PLAYS.  OVER
AND JAMYCHAL GREEN HAMMERS
>> CANCAR PLAYED S DIME.
JAYLEN S S>> Dave: THAT RIDICUL
GET OUT OF HERE, BLOCKED BY
JAMES.
>>>>E YOU JUST
GRABBED IT OUT OF THE AIR AND
GONE THE OTHER DIRECTION.  LIKE
PORTER JUNIOR
>> Greg: WHEW.
>> Johnny: SADDIQ OWE
BEING LOOK AT THAT, THROUGH THE
WICKETS, IT'S DEFINITELY A
THREE.METU, THREE, GOT IT! METUH
THESE
SITUATIONS WHERE THE
COMMUNICATION IS KEY.
BRIDGES, HALF ONCE AGAIN IN THE